ah clearing throats Greg John III is
upon us people John and I are not like
the most gaming knowledgeable like we're
not the most up-to-date let's say right
yeah I don't really like to see video
games
I do miss video games - I mean I just
finished injustice the first one but
some like 2013 that's the only like
closer recent game I play I really want
to play my video games because I really
do like that I've just have been so busy
with work
you know excuses but for e3 there's
other trailers that have dropped I know
I have Rihanna white and dance cyber or
arranging time some to come over in a
couple days that way we can shoot those
videos so we cannot just give a reaction
but an actual review with people who
know about games but John and I know a
little something and we thought we can
maybe you know have an opinion - about
spider-man oh yeah for ps4 there's
actually a lot of rave about this one
you have a ps4 you know I have a ps3 I
have a ps3 as well well maybe yes for
make this video more exciting for us we
should get a ps4 right now we should
let's go alright guys we just got ps4
and let's watch this let's do this
alright spider-man for Gamecube
do you think it some people see me and
think they're safer the wrong don't
really me they're seeing step promptly
for the best
following everything hinges on a guy
from Queens sounds as scary as it feels
yeah
[ __ ] off marble you feel pressure right
wow you are sipping through New York
they are cheap whoa nice
Wow
whoa oh my goodness how
oh man looks like you're contributing to
some chaos here it's not bad that isn't
like it liked it a lot I know a lot of
the most recent games of spider-man are
usually based on the movies that are
coming out well this is not this is a
little area based on any of the specific
films you know because it's got the
Spider Man set up the young dude young
Peter Parker in New York City's save and
correct let me saving crime-stopping
crap what it looks like they're throwing
down in this video game correct me if
I'm wrong but I think there is a certain
sort of idea that a lot of these like
video game tie-ins you know coming off
of hot movies or whatever are never like
super great the ratio of like really
quality video games to like it's cool
but not really that good rection like
except for like Arkham when it came to
Spider Man the free form was pretty cool
free run I don't say they don't they
don't I like the amazing spider-man 2 I
liked it I'm not saying they don't make
good ones I'm just saying they're out
fewer remedies that correct me if I'm
wrong and I was looking for that moment
found it I corrected this looks pretty
awesome it looks like maybe they're
finally throwing down and they're gonna
really try and make the Marvel video
games you know awesome too you know sort
of the vibe I got in this trailers like
wow they really want you to feel that
magic like it's in the movie yeah
because the DC games are [ __ ] killing
it right now so the fact that Marvel has
this song cuz everyone's excited again
about spider-man with spider-man home
Tommy coming out with him stealing the
show in civil war you know people are
like amped and I hear that the
spider-man animated movie might be about
Miles Morales actually so there's a lot
of hype around Spidey and this just
contributes to it because I remember the
first time I played an actual spider-man
video game I must have been like 14 or
you Johnny in the middle Knight level
must been around 14 or 15 was with my
cousin in New York at the time it's
spider-man 2 that's the first one where
they allowed you to actually go into the
streets cuz that was a little base off
Tobey Maguire and I've loved them ever
since I think they're all so [ __ ]
entertaining they're so fantastic and I
really love like zipping around as
spider-man can do it yeah it's great and
the fact that they haven't had
it's graphics and it sounds like the
moves you can do or even more insane
this could be like the ultimate
spider-man game huh The Ultimates my
mind oh yeah it looks a lot of fun I
mean it gave me that sort of same wonder
like I was watching that trailer and I
was like I want to play this like you
said zipping around town and dude web
trick yeah you know like having like
that's the most fun version of that to
me so so I think it's fine ran games
have been awesome ever since they
allegedly go into the streets because I
remember spider-man yawning again yeah
so are spider-man one the first one I
was based off the Sam Raimi one he would
jump off buildings but then if you went
to the street you know do that thing
where it's like whoa you're starting
again on top of the bill week they
didn't lie to actually go into the
streets this one you can like JIT now
it's [ __ ] insane you could literally
zip through all in New York it's going
you got like the Arkham games or you
could go through Gotham and stuff or
even visit the Arkham Asylum that's
another thing where it's like this is
like a real place you know like you are
it's very real and it looks and it looks
like they're honoring in the
architectural design of the whole city
and the vibe and stuff very well and it
gave me good the hope of them gave you
that magic you know
Oh spider Mike a Spider Man like you
know I'm not super well-read in comics
but spider-man's always been my favorite
and we're working on a spider-man stand
up for years starts off like this I was
surfing the web today oh my god
matters six years I've come up with I
think I'm like three jokes now I won
surfing the web sits like a family guy
cut away this is worse than that time
spider-man try doing stick listen
subscription services there's not enough
of them out there it'll subscribe today
become a reject do it yeah it's free
John his reasons to Jerry it's a
playlist on this channel go find out
what it's all about and he's a social
media manager for facebook.com slash
Blume house if you're into horror and
you like Facebook put the two together
take solar
it sounded like face sore